[Musique]
elles vont très très mal elles vont très
très mal puisque on a à ce jour perdu
près de 20% déjà des start up qui sont
ou en train de déposer bilan ou qui sont
en train d'arrêter totalement leurs
projets parce qu'elle en fait elle ne
bénéficie pas ne peuvent pas bénéficier
des des mesures qui ont été mis en place
par le gouvernement
et pour cause parce que en fait les
start up aujourd'hui ne sont pas des
entreprises normales sont elles ont un
statut des salaires ou deux et ça mais
dans leur fonctionnement elles ne
fonctionnent pas normalement il faut
savoir en fait qu'aujourd'hui l'impact
négatif sur les start up et les 80 % et
80 % des start up qui ont été impactés
par cette par cette crise
il ya deux milliards d'euros qui ont été
libérés par le gouvernement pour les
start up
si vous voulez 7,7 cet argent qui a été
libéré par l'état est soumis à une règle
et une loi qui est une loi européenne de
2014 qu'il dit en fait que ces
subventions ne peuvent aller à des
entreprises qui sont en difficulté
financière ou un solde négatif
or il faut savoir une chose c'est que la
plupart des start up dans l'eure dans
leur première année dans les trois à
cinq premières années elles ne feront
elles ne génèrent pas de chiffre
d'affaires elles sont totalement
toujours en dépenses pour la simple et
bonne raison c'est que avant de générer
du chiffre d'affaires il faut qu'elles
créent leurs produits
or nous on a on a on a vraiment la
triple peine
déjà on n'a pas de chance parce que on
devait commencer à faire du chiffre
d'affaires pour une fois on allait
commencer à faire du chiffre d'affaires
le jour où le premier ministre a a
interdit les événements de plus de 100
personnes
on était on était remorque chargée on
était sur la route en train de partir
pour le circuit du mans pour une grosse
manifestation pour porsche c'était notre
première manifestation et derrière on
devait enchaîner avec des manifestations
comme les 24 heures du mans moto les 24
heures du mans auto pas tout un tas de
choses qui allaient pouvoir me faire
entrer de l'argent
bon bah ça forcément avec le avec la
crise tout est tombé mais au-delà de ça
on était en pleine levée de fonds donc
du coup va toutes les levées de fonds il
faut savoir en fait que toutes les
levées de fonds se sont arrêtés nous on
a essayé de rebondir et on va proposer
en fait on propose à chaque personne
on cherche dix mille personnes sur 67
millions on devrait y arriver quand même
j'espère dix mille personnes en capacité
de places et je dis bien placé c'est pas
un don c'est placer de l'argent 50 euros
50 euros dix mille personnes
si on arrive à trouver dix mille
personnes qui place 50 euros et bien on
sauve notre projet